WE HAVE BEEN COVERING THE
REPUBLICANS NOW IT'S TIME TO GET
AN UPDATE ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE
OF THE RACE SURGING BERNIE
SANDERS.
>> BERNIE SANDERS IS DRAWING
MORE THAN 10,000 PEOPLE AN
APPEARANCE.
>> MORE THAN 15,000 PEOPLE
SHOWED UP AT HIS NEXT EVENT AND
THEN LAST NIGHT IN PORTLAND HEÑi
HAD THE BIGGEST CROWD YET, A
REPORTED 28,000 PEOPLE SHOWED
UP.
>> YEAH, AMERICA.
YEAH.
>> AMERICA, DO YOU FEEL A
BERNING SENSATION?
>> IF IT IS ANYTHING BUT
EMOTIONAL PLEASE CALL YOUR
DOCTOR.
>> IT SEEMS HE TAPPED INTO THE
POPULIST ID OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY AND SEEMS TO BE SURGING
AGAINST ITS EGO.
>> BUT WHY ARE PEOPLE PAYING
ATTENTION TO BERNIE SANDERS?  I
THOUGHT HE WAS JUST A CRAZY
SOCIALIST.
HE'S A SOCIALIST, RIGHT.
I MEAN, SERIOUSLY IT LOOKS LIKE
MR. MAGOO JUST WANDERED INTO THE
RACE.
OH I WILL BE PRESIDENT, WHY NOT,
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
OH, YEAH. FREE COLLEGE TUITION
>> HEY MILLENNIALS KNOW WHAT I
JUST DID?
I JUST NAILED MAGOO.
NAILED IT!  OH, LARRY, YOU
NAILED MAGOO.
BUT NOT EVERYBODY ON THE
PROGRESSIVE PARTY IS THAT
EXCITED TO HEAR HIM SPEAK.
IN FACT, SOME WON'T LET HIM
SPEAK AT ALL.
>> BLACK LIVES MATTER
PROTESTERS SHUTTING DOWN
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE BERNIE
SANDERS FORCING HIM TO LEAVE HIS
OWN RALLY ON SATURDAY IN
SEATTLE.
>> THANK YOU, SEATTLE FOR BEING
ONE OF THE MOST PROGRESSIVE
CITIES IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
>> SAY HER NAME? SAY HER NAME?
>> YOU KNOW THINGS ARE NOT GOING
WELL WHEN BLACK WOMEN UPEND
YOUR EVENT AND START RECITING
OLD LYRICS FROM DESTINY'S CHILD,
RIGHT?
>> ACTUALLY, THESE WOMEN ARE
FROM BLACK LIVES MATTER, WHO HAD
AN ISSUE WITH THE SANDERS
CAMPAIGN NOT PAYING ENOUGH
ATTENTION TO THEIR AGENDA.
NOW, LADIES, I AGREE THAT BLACK
LIVES MATTER BUT BLACK MANNERS
MATTER AS WELL.
ALL RIGHT?  AND JUST KEEPING IT
100, IF WE ARE KEEPING IT 100,
AND ALSO BASED ON THE
DEMOGRAPHICS, IF BERNIE SANDERS
RALLIES WERE A BEN AND JERRY'S
ICE CREAM FLAVOR, IT WOULD BE
NILLA, PLEASE.
>> KEEP IT 100.
KEEP IT 100.
>> THE CHOCOLATE'S IN THERE
SOMEWHERE, BUT YOU HAVE GOT TO
EAT A LOT OF VANILLA TO GET TO
IT.
THAT'S ALL I AM SAYING.
BUT THIS DIDN'T DERAIL BERNIE'S
CAMPAIGN, HE ACTUALLY LET THEM
SPEAK AND THEN HE HIRED A MEMBER
OF BLACK LIVES MATTER TO HIS
CAMPAIGN.
BUT NOT ALL -- YEAH, SURE.
BERNIE WAS VERY NICE.
HE WAS VERY GRACIOUS ABOUT IT.
BUT NOT ALL PEOPLE RESPECTED HIS
LETTING THE BLACK LADIES SPEAK.
>> I WOULD NEVER GIVE UP MY
MICROPHONE.
THAT SHOWED SUCH WEAKNESS.
THE WAY HE WAS TAKEN AWAY BY THE
TWO YOUNG WOMEN.
BELIEVE ME, THAT'S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN TO TRUMP.
>> Larry: THAT'S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN TO TRUMP?  IS THERE
ANOTHER TRUMP?  HE IS ALREADY
TALKING ABOUT HIMSELF IN THE
THIRD PERSON.
>> YEAH, YOU'RE WEAK SANDERS YOU
GOT BEAT BY GIRLS WITH BOOBS!  I
WOULD HAVE JUST BUILT A WALL
AROUND THE STAGE AND MADE MEXICO
PAY FOR IT.
ALL RIGHT?  THAT'S WHAT TRUMP
WOULD HAVE DONE.
I AM OFFICIALLY ENDORSING TRUMP.
ALL RIGHT.
SO HERE WE GO.
SO WE HAVE GOT THIS CRAZY
SOCIALIST WHO'S PROMISING FREE
COLLEGE, HAS THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
SHOWING UP TO HEAR HIM TALK.
AND WILL MAKE SURE BLACK WOMEN
WON'T YELL AT US.
OKAY?  SO IT SOUNDS PRETTY GOOD.
SO WHY ELSE SHOULD WE TAKE HIM
SERIOUSLY?  SANDERS HAS
DETHRONED HILLARY CLINTON IN NEW
HAMPSHIRE AFTER TRAILING HER BY
DOUBLE DIGITS BACK IN MARCH.
LOOK AT THAT.
>> Larry: OH, MY GOD.
OH, NO.
NO!  IS THIS HAPPENING AGAIN?  A
CANDIDATE OF PASSION IS ABOUT TO
OVERTAKE HILLARY?  SHE'S ABOUT
TO GET OBAMA'D BY AN OLD WHITE
MAN?  OH, MY GOSH.
I MEAN, LOOK, IT IS ONE THING
FOR A COOL BROTHER TO JUST BURST
ON THE SCENE AND ALL THAT
BROTHERNESS JUST SPILLS OUT ON
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
THAT'S JUST SCIENCE.
ALL RIGHT?  BUT WHEN PEOPLE ARE
MORE INSPIRED BY A GUY WHO
LOOKED LIKE THE ABOUT TO RETIRE
DEAN OF STUDENTS AT OBERLIN, I
HAVE TO ASK, YOU HAVE GOT TO
START ASKING, WHAT THE HELL IS
GOING ON?  OKAY.
SO FOR MORE ON THIS PHENOMENON
WE THOUGHT WE COULD CHECK IN
AGAIN WITH CLINTON CAMPAIGN
OFFICIAL CARLOS JORDANSON.Ñi
CARLOS, THANK YOU.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Larry: WELCOME BACK,
WELCOME BACK TO THE SHOW,
CARLOS.
I HAVE TO ASK YOU, ARE YOU
CONCERNED AT ALL ABOUT BERNIE
SANDERS'S RISING POPULARITY.
>> NO WAY.
WE HAVE GOT THE BLASE VOTE
LOCKED UP IN THIS ELECTION.
YEAH.
IF IT IS GOING TO BE HILLARY
VERSUS JEB IN A BATTLE OF
ATTRITION. THAT'S WHY I'M
INTRODUCING OUR SLOGAN:
HILLARY 2016, HASN'T AMERICA HAD
ENOUGH EXCITEMENT FOR A WHILE?
OUR NEW CAMPAIGN SLOGAN.
>> THAT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE THE
BEST KIND OF SLOGAN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS THE
PROBLEM?  DO YOU THINK LIBERALS
AREN'T EXCITED BECAUSE SHE IS
NOT LIBERAL ENOUGH?
>> I GUESS THAT POSSIBLE, LARRY
IT JUST HAS NOT BEEN IMPORTANT.
WHEN YOU HAVE GOT SOMEONE LIKE
BERNIE SANDERS WHO IS EXCITING
AND GENUINE AND WHO NO ONE
DOUBTS CARES ABOUT THE MIDDLE
CLASS, I MEAN, THAT GUY -- HE'S
LIKE A DREAM FOR A PROGRESSIVE
LIKE ME WHO ISN'T ALREADY LOCKED
INTO THIS OTHER CAMPAIGN.
>> Larry: WHOA, WHOA, WHOA,
WHOA.
WAIT, HOLD ON.
CARLOS, CARLOS.
I SOUNDS LIKE YOU ARE NOT THAT
EXCITED ABOUT HER.
YOU ARE MORE EXCITED ABOUT
BERNIE.
>> OH, NO.
>> THIS GUY.
IT IS LIKE -- IT IS LIKE THIS.
>> Larry: OKAY.
>> YOU KNOW HOW SOMETIMES YOU
ARE DRIVING WITH SOME FRIENDS
AND YOU GO TO SIX FLAGS FOR THE
DAY BUT INSTEAD YOU END UP AT
THE DENTIST'S OFFICE BUT YOU
STILL HAVE A GREAT TIME.
THAT'S ALL THIS IS.
>> Larry: NO, NO, HOLD ON.
>> YES.
>> Larry: HILLARY'S, YOU ARE
COMPARING HILLARY'S CAMPAIGN TO
A TRIP TO THE DENTIST'S OFFICE,
THAT DOES NOT SOUND GOOD.
>> WHAT IS YOUR NEXT QUESTION?
>> Larry: LOOK.
I REALLY BELIEVE THIS IS ABOUT
PASSION, WHEN ELIZABETH WARREN
DECIDED NOT TO RUN.
>> STOP, STOP, STOP.
SHE WILL HEAR YOU.
>> Larry: ELIZABETH WARREN?
>> AH, NO! SHE IS NOT, SHE WHO
IS NOT ELIZABETH WARREN.
>> SORRY
NOW, I DON'T WANT TO GET YOU IN
TROUBLE.
>> THAT'S WHERE THE EXCITEMENT
IS WHEN I MENTION NAMES LIKE
ELIZABETH WARREN --.
>> I THINK THAT IS ALL THE TIME
WE HAVE.
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK!
>> Larry: NO, NO, NO.
>> WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
>> Larry: I SAY WE WILL BE
RIGHT BACK.
>> I FEEL LIKE YOU ARE AVOIDING
AT ALL ISSUES, CARLOS, LOOK LET
ME JUST SAY, YES, I FEEL LIKE
YOU ARE NOT EXCITED ABOUT YOUR
CANDIDATE.
YOU ARE MORE EXCITED ABOUT OTHER
CANDIDATES AND THAT'S A BIG
ISSUE.
HOW DO YOU THINK HILLARY CAN
WIN?.
>> HEY, MAN, WHY DO YOU HAVE TO
BE SO FOCUSED ON EXCITEMENT?  0
YOU KNOW, LIKE, OH, EXCITEMENT.
HEY I AM EXCITED TO EAT BROCCOLI
BECAUSE IT CONTAINS VITAMINS,
YOU DIG?  THAT IS WHAT
HILLARY IS, SHE IS EATING
BROCCOLI.
IN FACT THAT'S OUR NEW NEW
SLOGAN, VOTE FOR HILLARY,
SHE'S YOUR BROCCOLI, AMERICA.
>> Larry: THAT'S ENOUGH.
00:07:42,395 --> 00:00:00,000
CARLOS JORDANSON, EVERYBODY!  WE
WILL BE RIGHT BACK!